why middle-aged women can't find a good
guy
this one's diverse from a woman that
wanted to know why she's struggling
finding a good guy she's in her early
40s professional making about 220 000 a
year the first reason why you're
struggling is because you have a very
narrow dating pool if you're a
professional woman in your 40s or 50s
you've got a few pieces of paper on the
wall framed in mahogany the problem is
is that generally speaking guys are not
attracted to degrees men are success
objects to women women are beauty
objects to men successful men that you'd
like to date they generally date younger
hotter more agreeable women the quality
of women in that age bracket aren't
long-term relationship type of material
they've got a notch count they often
bring small children in tow they're also
fairly disagreeable and then of higher
caliber
this he throws this word around a lot he
loves this word agreeable
it sounds to me often times when i hear
him talk like he wants um rather than a
wife or a partner more of like a
compliant
housekeeper
sex robot i don't know i don't know what
to term it but i'm not really sure i
would like to dig a little bit more with
him he's obviously not here to discuss
what do you mean by agreeable and why
the assumption that somebody who was in
her 40s and 50s who was successful would
somehow be disagreeable problem that why
is that why is
that automatically a correlation for him
i would be curious to ask
he also talks about high caliber
men and what they want again high
caliber is a debatable word
two words debatable expression it seems
to me that some people identify high
caliber as primarily how much money is
in your wallet and how much financial
and work success you've had
there is a whole bunch of people that
will define high caliber
has your character primarily and yes
your ambition your motivation your yes
of course your academic successes maybe
your professional successes
whether or not you
sleep around can you be trusted are you
a good friend are you a good son are you
a good uh brother
many many things go into what a high
caliber man is
too many that may not fit the definition
of what he's saying a high calibration
but a high caliber man who's
diverse
and has all those attributes
they're not going to want a robot
they're not trying to just boss somebody
around or a puppy dog they can pat on
the head and say you've been agreeable
today
again that agreeable person when you
when [ __ ] hits the fan and you need
somebody like something happens in
business something happens with your
health and you need to bounce off
somebody what are you gonna what are you
gonna say to them
what do you think we should do whatever
dear
whatever makes you happy dear
stafford wife
no they want
hey but what do you think i should do do
you want to do this you
there's no point
don't get married don't bother don't do
any of that if you're looking for an
agreeable dog get a dog and train it
really really well because even dogs
aren't always agreeable 100 of the time
so there are good points again yes you
do you narrow your dating pool if you're
40s and 50s is it narrower 100 there's
going to be a lot of guys out there that
want to have kids now you're not going
to be in an age bracket to have kids is
that a legitimate point yes
are all men focused on your career
success the way you are no
some of them may not care about that are
you in your prime do you look the best
you've ever looked in your life in your
40s and 50s well most don't
most don't do some yeah i'm sure it's
possible there could have been somebody
that didn't take care of themselves when
they were young
who was overweight who was not into
health
and then got older got fit got a new
lease on life you know
maybe
sure those people exist but the majority
of people do they look better younger
when they're younger
yes
yes that's just a fact right this should
be controversial so some of the stuff
he's saying yes great points
but
if you're talking about women like you
want somebody to be agreeable
you're not looking for a partner
so audience just know what they're
saying
they're giving in advice off of they're
giving advice off the premise that
you're not looking for a partner
that you're looking for an
agreeable little puppy dog
willing to be the main
while you have you know whatever going
on
all that that whole image if that's not
what you want maybe this isn't the
advice that you take
just think about that okay i'm not
saying they're wrong on everything
but they get a lot wrong if you like the
short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]